so you might be finding that you might
set out to do nice clean clear wheel
plans and the poi kind of maybe drift in
towards each other
oh it away from each other in together
at the top or at the bottom and that's
that's normal
and there's some things you can do to
work on this one of the big ones is
really looking and playing with what
you're actually doing with your hand
this circle would be poi and for this
it's really helpful like a lot of things
where you can actually play with a wall
um so you're gonna need to thing you're
gonna need somehow wall and you're gonna
need a stick a little stick but not just
any little stick you need a special a
really special stick um
but you get to decide that it's special
so I've decided that this is a special
stick and you can find a stick in the
side that it's a special stick and what
you're gonna do is you're going to come
up to a wall and I want you to just take
the stick and then you can pretend it's
a marker and make some circles I don't
notice you need to make a big circular
scooping motion scoop scoop scoop and
maybe that's gonna be awkward at first
and do it enough till your hand you know
and all that like neural motor feedback
stuff that happens to be like Oh circles
and this is scooping and you go
backwards and scooping backwards
scooping backward you go each way each
hand you know take your left hand loose
make circles for words oh and this is
more awkward circles backwards you'll be
perfect our body actually not designed
to make perfect circles we're sort of
taking apparatus that was originally
involved do other stuff and using it to
make circles but you start recruiting a
lot more of your fingers and wrists in
hand
and then when you go with the POI try to
make the same scooping motion so you see
how I'm really like if that was the tip
of a marker I'd be drawing a circle on
the wall so and what if I you watch well
I people when they're learning they're
actually just kind of going like up and
down or something and you want have a
lot of control on the poi with open it
now up and down can be great because up
and down is what lets you do this we'll
talk about that later so it's all been
having choice and recruiting you know at
will a lot of your body and motor skills
to do stuff so forwards and backwards
and the wall give you a lot of feedback
really pretend you're drawing a circle
and learn now I can do this where I've
got both poi going only ones against the
wall but they look at that right hand
and I'm drawing a circle go forwards I'm
still drawing a circle and the sooner
you do that the sooner you'll have a lot
of control over the tilt I can draw
circles in front of me draw circles to
the side I can draw a circle on the
ceiling above me and that's for all the
control comes from so takes playing with
a little bit but really if you if you
actually give yourself where you've got
a bit of visceral feedback it comes
really quickly so I hope that works I
hope you find a special stick you could
use a marker or crown you know patent
them but that you know will leave marks